fue justo en el vídeo pasado cuando
empezamos a hablar acerca de sistemas de
ecuaciones y sobre qué eran los sistemas
de ecuaciones y en el vídeo pasado
analizamos cómo resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones por el método gráfico sin
embargo en esta ocasión lo que quiero
ver es un sistema de ecuaciones pero
analizado de una manera algebraica así
que lo primero que voy a hacer es poner
aquí las dos ecuaciones la primera va a
ser x + 2 james esto voy a decir que es
igual a 9 y la siguiente va a ser 3x + 5
james esto voy a decir que es igual a 20
esto va a ser igual a 20 muy bien ahora
lo que quiero que recuerdes es que en el
vídeo pasado lo que hacíamos era tomar
estas ecuaciones y ponerlas en su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen otras veces
punto pendiente lo cual ya sabemos hacer
darnos cuenta que era una recta y
graficar ambas rectas en un plano
cartesiano para ver en qué punto se
interceptaban en esta ocasión lo que
quiero ver es un nuevo método un método
más algebraico y este método es el
método de sustitución es decir me voy a
aplicar a una de estas ecuaciones voy a
despejar a una de estas variables sea x
o sea james y la voy a meter en la otra
ecuación la pueden enchufar en la
segunda ecuación y bueno para que poco a
poco te vaya quedando mucho más claro
vamos a hacerlo no voy a tomar la
primera ecuación que es x + 2 y igual a
9 y lo que voy a hacer es despejar a x y
para esto voy a restar 2 y de ambos
lados de la ecuación entonces del lado
izquierdo me queda solamente x mientras
que del lado derecho me queda 9 menos 2
james 2 jay menos 2 ya se van y
solamente me queda x igual a 9 a menos
dos ya perfecto ya tengo una expresión
para x aquí no está diciendo que x tiene
que ser igual a 9 menos o bien pero como
tiene que cumplir las dos ecuaciones
entonces esta misma x es esta x de la
que tengo en la segunda ecuación aquí
tengo una expresión para x x es igual al
9 - dossier pero esta x es la misma x de
la otra ecuación porque tiene que
cumplir ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente
por lo tanto en la segunda ecuación en
lugar de poner a x voy a poner a 9 menos
2 james y me queda 3 que multiplica x
pero x es 9 menos 2 james ya esto le voy
a sumar 5 y esto
tiene que ser igual a 20 lo único que
usted es siendo substituyendo el valor
de x adentro en la segunda ecuación
porque recuerdan ya sabemos que x vale
92 de la primera ecuación y bueno
cuántos estos tres por 927 de tres por
menos dos y es menos 6 james ya esto le
voy a sumar 5 y esto es igual a 20 lo
único que hice fue distribuir este 3
adentro del paréntesis y después voy a
reducir términos semejantes menos 65
james es lo mismo que menos 1 y entonces
me queda 27 - james es igual a 20 y
ahora qué pasa si sumo de ambos lados de
la ecuación menos 27 si te das cuenta lo
que estamos haciendo es logrando
despejar hay en 10 que me va a quedar
bueno de este lado 27 27 se van me queda
menos james mientras que del lado
izquierdo me queda un 20 menos 27 es
menos 7 y habrá sin el valor de 10 que
satisface a ambas ecuaciones es igual a
7 se multiplicó ambos lados por menos 1
o pasos de signo menos del otro lado me
queda que y igual a 7 es el valor del
yen que satisface a ambas ecuaciones
logré sustituyendo encontré una
expresión para x la cual enchufe en la
segunda ecuación y entonces ya tengo que
es igual a 7 perfecto una vez que ya
tengo que es igual a 7 que te parece que
de aquí de esta expresión que tengo aquí
para x voy a sustituir ahora el valor
que tengo de james que vale 7 por lo
tanto x es igual a 9 menos 2 por 7 o sea
que x es igual a 9 menos 14 lo cual me
dice que x es igual a 9 unos 14 que es
menos 5 ya tengo también el valor para x
el par x igual a menos 5 y 7 son los dos
valores que cumplen simultáneamente
ambos de ecuaciones o dicho de otra
manera el punto menos 57 es el punto de
intersección de estas dos rectas y es
más vamos a verificarlo si x vale menos
5 y lleva las 7 en la primera ecuación
me quedan menos 5 2 por 7 x 14 y esto es
igual a 9 y en la otra ecuación me queda
3 x menos 5 lo cual es menos 15 más 5
por 7 5 por 7 35 y 35 menos 15 es 20
perfecto cumplen ambas ecuaciones
es el segundo método para resolver
sistemas de ecuaciones que quería ver
contigo ahora vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo pero este ejemplo vamos a
complicarlo un poco más porque quiero
ver un problema que tenga que ver con un
sistema de ecuaciones que a su vez lo
resolvamos por el método de sustitución
así que el problema dice lo siguiente la
suma de dos números la suma de dos
números esto es exactamente igual a 70
la suma de dos números 70 y la
diferencia de estos dos números es 11 la
diferencia o la resta de estos dos
números es 11 así que tenemos dos
números que su suma es 70 y sus
diferencias 11 y bueno la pregunta es
cuáles son estos dos números cuáles son
estos números y bueno lo primero que hay
que hacer cuando tenemos un problema
como éste es definir variables es un
consejo que te doy el problema lo
tenemos de una forma abstracta pero
cuando nosotros escribimos un lenguaje
matemático podemos llegar a resolverlo
entonces voy a bautizar a x como el
número más grande y ahí como el número
más pequeño me estoy tomando 2
arbitrarias así que puedes cambiar las
variables o el nombre de las variables
no importa pero lo importante es ponerle
el nombre a las variables y bueno vamos
a leer la primera oración que dice la
suma de estos dos números es decir la
suma de x más la suma de james esto
tiene que ser igual a 70 la suma de dos
números es igual a 70 o dicho de otra
manera x + james es igual a 70 y su
diferencia es 11 por lo tanto como la
diferencia es positiva me voy a tomar el
número más grande que es x ya este
número le voy a quitar james y me va a
dar 11 que por cierto la diferencia de
un número muy grande menos un número
pequeño me va a dar algo positivo muy
bien y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
resolver el tema de cuestiones por
sustitución ya tengo dos ecuaciones con
25 gritas y para resolver este tema de
ecuaciones voy a resolverlo por
sustitución así que me voy a fijar en la
segunda actuación en la segunda ecuación
voy a despejar a x y para esto vean
sumar 10 de ambos lados de la ecuación
más bien el lado izquierdo más ya del
lado derecho de tal manera que esto se
cancela y me queda que x es igual a 11 +
james hoye + 11 ya tengo aquí despejada
de esta segunda ecuación x es igual a 11
ojo aquí ya tenemos a la variable x
despejada en términos de la otra
variable de la variable james y bueno
como estamos utilizando el método de
sustitución lo que vamos a hacer es
enchufar esta x en la primera ecuación
porque recuerda que esta x tendrá que
cumplir ambas ecuaciones es la misma x
que tenemos en la primera ecuación y por
lo tanto en lugar de x voy a poner más
11 10 más 11 + james esto tiene que ser
igual a 70 que más 11 mayer es igual a
70 ya esté más 11 no lo pierdas de vista
porque estella más 11 es mi x la equis
que estoy enchufando en la primera
ecuación es justo por eso que la despeje
de la segunda ecuación y bueno ya tengo
que llamar son c mayer es igual a 70
date cuenta que ya tenemos una ecuación
con sólo una incógnita por lo tanto esto
ya está muy fácil de resolver
lleva así que me quedan demás 11 may efe
es igual a 70 y si sumo james maye me
queda que 2 más 11 esto es igual a 70 y
si pasamos el 11 del otro lado lo que
voy a hacer es estar 11 de ambos lados
de la ecuación y me queda
no siempre es igual a 70 menos 11 lo
cual es 59 y ahora para despejar a james
lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 2 y nos queda
que james es igual a 59 medios o lo que
es lo mismo a 2030 menos a 29.5 si
fíjate bien 60 entre 2 es 30 pero le voy
a quitar 11 entre 2 es un medio o 1.5
entonces me queda 29.5 y es igual a 59
medios o 29.5 y perfecto ya tengo el
valor de james ahora lo que hay que
sacar es el valor de x pero ya tengo a
la equis aquí despejada x es igual a ye
más 11 pero lleva al de 29.5 entonces me
queda 29.5 más 11 lo cual es 30-40 40.5
40.5 x es igual a 40.5 es decir que la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
es x igual a 40.5 de igual a 29.5 o
dicho de otra manera la intersección de
ambas rectas es el punto 40.5 29.5 y
como logré la solución de éste
adecuaciones y graficar lo con el método
de sustitución este fue el primer método
que estamos viendo en el cual hay que
despejar a una de las variables de
alguna de las dos ecuaciones y después
sustituir el valor de esta variable en
términos de la otra en la otra ecuación
y bueno ya para finalizar el vídeo vamos
a ver si esta solución cumple ambas
ecuaciones es decir 40.5 + 29.5 esto
tiene que ser igual a 70 que es lo mismo
que 40 más 30 que 70 perfecto y por otra
parte 40.5 menos 29.5 es lo mismo que 11
cumplen ambas ecuaciones